hello my name is Jeffrey I wanted to let
you know I watch the shows before I read
the books and as I'm reading through
them I'm really sort of mesmerized by
the foreshadowing elements that you use
and sometimes it seems more like a
political mystery than it does a high
fantasy can you talk about your
technical process for creating the
puzzle that we have to put together as
readers I don't talk about them but I'm
not sure you you have any more success
and understanding the answer than I did
with the Trinity I just think of these
things and and you know I put in things
that I think I'll pay off later little
hints and foreshadowing thank you as you
do and sometimes I do pay them off and
sometimes later in the book I could go
back and take out the foreshadowing
because I sort of drifted away from them
but but a lot of it takes place on a
subconscious level there are writers
writers working very different ways and
I've often said there are two main types
of writers the architect and the
gardener and the architect plans
everything ahead of time very
painstakingly like an art architect
designing a house he knows how many
floors they're going to be in how many
rooms on each floor and where the
plumbing is going to go and where the
plug is going to go in each room and
what the roof is going to be made of and
etc and all of this is determined that
little printed out before the first
board is so no the first nail is driven
the gardener just sort of plants a seed
and he waters it then he sees what comes
up and you know he knows certain things
he knows whether he planted an avocado
or an oak tree but a lot of it is much
more organic and I think what writers
are combinations of these very few of
pure architectural herb gardeners but
they lean one way or another and I'm
much more gardener than I am
architect as for other writers like
cocaine for example was also much more
gardener but there are are taken
architects out there so a lot of my
process takes place and I don't know
where it's coming from but its ideas
come to me in concept to come to me and
I work with them I've got a kind of
maybe a two part backstory question when
Brynden rivers bloodraven cleared the
path for egg Egan was it a was his exile
to the wall a wink and a nod or a
devastating political punishment it was
not a weakened inaud
you know it's what bloodraven did was
pretty unethical and could even count it
as evil although you know by his lights
necessary and you know something that
probably put egg on the fifths rain on a
on a sound basis but a great course to
his own personal honor and I think to
clear the way Aegon had to had to get
rid of blood ribbon thank you Matt um
just wondering uh with in the first book
when the Starks are heading to King's
Landing Ned and Sanson aria you know
arias wolf is I mean Santa's wolf is
killed and then arias goes missing or
she sends it away I was wondering if
there's any kind of symbolism there like
you know this dark within Santa's dead
or the stork within re is missing if I'm
just reading way too much do that or you
know that's an interesting thing to
contemplate that it's good that you're
contemplating it
well said Argost still has a connection
to her wolf and says you if you read to
her chapter she's still having to go for
her gia and I'm area is still roaming
the the Riverlands at the head of a
gigantic mother wolf so is there
something going on perhaps just gonna
have to wait hi my name is Sarah I was
wondering what's one question that you
always sort of hope somebody will ask
you at these sorts of things would you
mind answering it I have many questions
that I wish people would not ask me but
a question I'm actually dying to be
asked you know I don't don't really have
one okay how about the things you don't
want people ask who's my favorite
character when will the next book be out
where do you get your ideas
yeah I gotta yada yada you know the same
old questions that I get asked all the
time yeah my least favorite question of
course is do you know who's going to
finish the books when you die which I do
get from from time to time and I've been
known to react to that testily thank you
for your time my name is Carlton my
question to try to avoid the question
that you don't like about your favorite
character or otherwise obviously most of
us we really love Ice and Fire Game of
Thrones great series thank you what in
all of your writing would you say is
your favorite story that you have read
well
early in my career I wrote a lot of
short stories and there's still some
people think my short stories are my
best work but I'd like to write more
short stories eventually if I live long
enough it's he's doing I hope but you
know I've written some short stories
that I'm very pleased with going all the
way back to my first you go win
ourselves R'lyeh and then relatively
more recent things like fortresses
children were from the nebula and this
tower of ashes
you know they add the ice dragon which
has been published separately as a
children's book I know a number of you
have had me sign it but it was
originally just a a short story that's
some of my best work I think it all
through the 80s I've read on the you
know religiously I know all the other
financial magazines and for some reason
the pear-shaped man always stuck in my
head out of everything I read through
did 380s so there's there's a lasting
use in the short stories thank you
short stories were central science
fiction they're so important yeah
they're still important they're not as
important as they were they don't
dominate the way they did in the in
certainly the 40s or the 50s but or even
the 70s and 80s when I was breaking it
but they're still the way that a lot of
new writers make their bones get their
names out there establish establish